>> The Library of Congress
in Washington DC.
>> John Cole: Well, good morning.
>> Audience: Good morning.
>> John Cole: And welcome
to the Library of Congress.
I'm John Cole.
I'm the Director of the Center for
the Book in the Library of Congress,
and I'm glad to welcome
you to a special ceremony
where we are inaugurating or at
a well-known inaugural ceremony,
our Fifth National Ambassador
four Young People's Literature.
The Center for The Book is fortunate
to have many important co-sponsors,
of course, in this
wonderful program.
You're going to hear from them
in a minute, but in the meantime,
I'm going to tell you just a little
bit about the Center for the Book,
which was established in 1977
as a public/private partnership.
We have a law authorizing
what we do, but it also infers
that we will raise private
money to pay for our activities,
which we are pleased to do,
and that's where the
partnerships come in.
Our purpose is to, on behalf of the
Library of Congress, promote books
and reading and literacy
and libraries.
We accomplish this mission not only
through events such as this one
at the Library of Congress
and many other events but also
through a major role in the National
Book Festival, which I know many
of you know about, but also
through the nationwide networks
of state affiliates, and that's
one of the reasons are so pleased
to have people from
around the country here,
and that our ambassador will
be visiting various places
around the country to spread the
good word about the importance
of reading and books
for young people.
We also have an affiliate
program of organizations,
and the Children's Book
Council, our major sponsor here,
is one of the members
of that network,
but one of our key endeavors,
in fact, brings us here today.
This program was established
by the Children's Book Council
and the Center for the Book, in this
Children's Book Council Foundation,
Every Child a Reader,
way back in 2008.
It doesn't seem to us, to those
of us who have been involved,
that it's been that long, actually,
but we have living proof here today
with a couple of the
former ambassadors,
and you will meet them later.
Our program's aim is to raise
national awareness of the importance
of young people's literature as it
relates to literacy, to education,
into something much
bigger, the betterment
of the lives of our young people.
Appointed for a two-year term,
the National Ambassador chooses a
personal platform relating to books
and reading, which you
will also hear about.
It's the Librarian of Congress
takes the appointment based
on recommendations of a committee
of experts who has helped,
and many members of the
committee are here today.
The Center for the Book, in addition
to the programs I've mentioned,
administers the Library's
Poetry and Literature Center
and its Young Readers Center,
which was created in 2009,
and at the Young Reader's Center,
which I hope you will visit today.
Is in this building, and
you'll be guided there.
We not only have books written
by our new National Ambassador,
whoever he or she may be.
There's a big surprise
announcement coming.
Plus, for their parents
and their caregivers.
Technically, it's down on
room G-29 of the ground floor
of this beautiful Jefferson
Building.
There also is a special
display, became available today,
in the window leading to
the Young Readers Center
where you can learn the identity of
our brand-new National Ambassador,
and inside the Young Readers
Center is a display of works,
not only by the new ambassador, but
by all the previous ambassadors.
I want to extend a special
welcome today to guests
from the Savoie Elementary School.
Where the world can they be?
Can I hear from them?
Are they someplace nearby?
Let's hear another yay!
Raise your hands.
[ Applause ]
Let's try that one more time.
We've now rehearsed it.
I want to extend a special
welcome to our guests
from the Savoie Elementary School.
Can we hear from them?
There we go.
They will, I must say,
logistically speaking,
will be leaving the room the first
because each of them is then,
after we are done this
part of the ceremony,
because they will each be
receiving a signed copy
of a book by our new ambassador.
Well, I will say just a quick
word for how many of you,
this is the first visit to
the Library of Congress?
Would you raise your hand?
A lot of the kids.
A number of the adults.
This beautiful building
was opened in 1897.
Our first home was the US
capital because we were created
when the capital moved
to Washington in 1800.
So we have a long history.
Our other big buildings on this
campus are the John Adams Building,
which opened in 1980 -- excuse
me, in 1998; 1939, I'm sorry.
I'm a historian.
I haven't got my dates.
I'm in the wrong century
half of the time,
but I do know when the Madison
Building opened, which was 1980.
So we have these three major
buildings, and I hope you come back
after you visit the
Young Readers Center.
You'll see some of the other glories
of this building, and learn more
about the Library of Congress.
I would now like to introduce you
to the acting Librarian
of Congress, David Mao.
David oversees this whole entire
library that I've tried to describe
and its various service units,
and we serve the Congress first,
but we serve all of
the American people.
We are also a public library, which
lots of people don't seem to know,
but we're working hard
to let them know,
and the Young Readers Center
is the principal way we do it.
David has big picture.
He served as Deputy Librarian
of Congress for a short period.
During his time as
Deputy, David oversaw kind
of a strategic alignment.
We're trying to figure out where
we're headed, because right now,
the post of Librarian of Congress,
which the presidential
appointment, is still open.
We're still waiting to see
what's going to happen,
but in the meantime, we've
been lucky to have David,
and we've also had an appointment
of a new Chief Operating Officer,
and under David also, the hiring
of a new Chief Information Officer,
and as I mentioned, David
has broad experience.
Before being named Deputy Librarian,
he was our 23rd Law
Librarian of Congress.
As Law Librarian, he managed the
operation of one of our major units,
which has the world's biggest --
there are lots of world's
biggest connected with the Library
of Congress -- collection
of legal materials,
and it serves as leading
research center for foreign,
comparative, and international law.
David often described the position
as part Lock Librarian to Congress,
part steward for law
collections, and part ambassador --
there's that word -- to the world's
legal and library communities.
Please welcome David Mao.
David.
[ Applause ]
>> David Mao: Thank
you so much, John,
for that very kind
introduction, and welcome everyone
to the Library of Congress.
Now, boys and girls, remember when
I came in and you were standing
down in the hall, what
did I tell you
about ignoring what your teachers
and your parents always tell you
about being inside the
building, and inside voices.
I was hoping that you would really
be very generous with their spirit.
So let's try again, I think
John was trying to get you
to show your spirit here.
So welcome again to the Library
of Congress from the kids and --
>> Audience Speaker: Savoie.
>> David Mao: Savoie.
Come on. No inside voices.
All right, all right.
Thank you.
Again, it's my pleasure to
welcome all of you to the Library
of Congress for this very,
very important event.
So we celebrate the
National Ambassador
for Young People's Literature,
and that is a very important role,
because it is this National
Ambassador that, since 2008,
since John has mentioned, going out
and traveling the nation and talking
to boys and girls and
talking to, well, adults, too,
about the importance of literature,
young people's literature, reading,
literacy, all of these things that
are very, very important, and,
boys and girls, I hope
you take that to heart,
and you will soon see
why it's so important
when we introduce our
new ambassador.
But before we do that, we're very,
very fortunate, as John mentioned,
that we have a couple of our
previous ambassadors here with us,
Kate DiCamillo and Jon
Scieszka, who started us off,
and both of them did fabulous jobs
during their tenures as ambassadors,
spreading the word about what we
do here at the Library of Congress
and just generally the word about
literature and books and reading.
I want to now officially welcome our
new, and announce our new ambassador
for young people's literature.
His name is Gene Luen Yang, and he's
going to come up in just a second.
I wanted to say one thing, though.
I think many of you are
ready knew that he was going
to be our ambassador, and I
had the fortunate privilege
of being mistaken for him.
So, if there's one benefit, you
know, nobody knows who I am.
Now people think I'm
the new Ambassador
for Young People's Literature, and
John had mentioned as Law Librarian,
I thought of myself
as the ambassador
to the world's legal community.
Now I can really say that I'm
ambassador to all of the world,
and so, thank you, John --
I'm sorry, Gene, for
giving me that privilege.
So students, are you ready?
>> Students: Yeah!
>> David Mao: Okay,
now that's better.
We very much.
We will now introduce Gene, can
I invite John for coming up.
Is that what is to do, Jon?
Am I supposed to invite
you up to introduce him?
>> John Cole: Yes, you may.
>> David Mao: Okay, all right,
we'll do that, and again,
thank you for being here everyone,
and we will now hear from John.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Well, we'll hear
from David again, because in one
of his pockets, I hope, he has a
metal that is going to be presented
to the Ambassador,
Gene, in a few minutes,
but I would like to just make
the point that having Gene
and the ambassador is a
very special thing for us.
Both it shows we have continuity
in this program that is going
to be stretching across
our country and stretching
to different audiences
at different levels,
and we view our Young Readers
Center, which you'll see is kind
of the hope for the activity kind
of effort, but also as a model,
and as our ambassadors have
gone around the country
and have developed and
learned about new programs,
they've shared those ideas with
all of us, and I know Gene is going
to the same, but for the
record, and just to get this more
of a momentous occasion, I
would like everyone to stand
and applaud our new
ambassador, Gene Luen Yang.
Gene.
[ Applause ]
You will hear from
Gene in a few minutes,
and Kate and Jon, please stand.
Stay up. The work recognition,
actually, of Jon Scieszka
and Kate DiCamillo,
our other ambassadors.
[ Applause ]
Jon was our first ambassador, and
so we broke each other in in terms
of what is expected
of an ambassador,
and one of the things Jon taught
me that he took that metal,
and he never took it off,
and the other thing is
that he still expects me to
come up with a model helicopter
that will sort of, he wanted one to
kind of fly him around Washington DC
as the ambassador and
make appearances.
So it's still on the agenda, Jon.
We're a government agency.
It takes a little while.
As I mentioned earlier,
our cosponsor is a
Children's Book Council,
which is an important partner
for us, and especially important
for this project, and its
foundation, Every Child a Reader,
is our major financial supporter
in many ways for this activity,
and it's my pleasure to
introduce another John.
Not a Jon, a Jon Coleman,
who is the Executive Director
of the Children's Book
Council, for remarks.
Jon.
>> Thanks, John.
[ Applause ]
>> Jon Coleman: Hello
everyone, I'm Jon Coleman.
I'm the Executive Director of
the Children's Book Council,
the nonprofit trade organization
for children's book publishers
in North America that's dedicated
to supporting the industry
and promoting children's books and
reading, and Every Child a Reader,
a nonprofit, which works
to instill a lifelong love
of reading in children.
Since the National Ambassador
Program's inception eight years ago,
we have been honored to have
four exceptionally beloved
and respected children's
books creators take
up the ambassador mental, serving as
the country's preeminent advocates
for lifelong literacy
and the joy of reading.
Jon Scieszka, our inaugural
ambassador, paved the way in 2008,
focusing on transforming reluctant
readers into enthusiastic once.
Said Jon, "There is no one book
that is right for all kids,
but there are all kinds
of crazy, interesting,
and amazing books out there.
It's our job to help kids find
that book that will inspire them
to want to become readers."
As a children's book writer,
former elementary school teacher,
and founder of Guide's Read, A
Literacy Initiative for Boys,
Jon was exceptionally skilled at
generating excitement around reading
and motivating kids want to read.
Our second national ambassador,
Katherine Paterson's Read
for Your Life platform, focused on
encouraging reluctant young readers
to find that truly engage them,
in order to build a strong,
lifelong love of reading.
As Katherine said, "I think all of
the joy of reading has given me --
it's not just because it is good for
you, but it is because it is good."
Walter Dean Myers,
our third ambassador,
selected Reading is Not
Optional as his platform.
His stance on literacy was
that it should be positioned
as a pleasant adjunct
to life, but instead,
is integral to lifelong
growth and development.
Walter said, "I think what we
need to do is say reading is going
to really affect your life.
You take a man who doesn't have
a job but you say to him, 'Look,
you can make a difference in
your child's life just by reading
to him for 30 minutes a day.'
That's what I would like to do."
Walter was particularly interested
in reaching underserved communities
and visiting incarcerated teens
in juvenile detention
centers throughout his tenure.
He was also committed to
getting parents to read
to their very young children
to help close the literacy gap.
Kate DiCamilla, our
most recent ambassador,
championed the community-unifying
power of storytelling.
During her tenure, Kate
participated in a variety
of community reads
programming from coast-to-coast,
bringing communities together with
the power of the written word.
In Kate's words, "When we
read together, we can act.
Together we see the world.
Together we see one another."
Over the last eight years,
the National Ambassador Program has
reached millions of young readers
and their caregivers in the United
States through schools, libraries,
bookstores, community centers,
prisons, museums, and beyond.
In August of this year, we
convened our suction committee
for the 2016-2017 ambassadorship.
The committee is composed of the
following individuals, Betsy Berg,
Election Development Manager
of Evanston Public Library,
Shelley M. Diaz, Senior Editor,
Reviews at School Library Journal,
Kate DiCamillo, National Ambassador
for Young People's Literature,
2014-2015, Jonathan Hunt,
Coordinator of the
Library Media Services
at the San Diego County office
of Education, Kimberly L. Jones,
store manager at Little Shop
of Stories, Decatur, Georgia,
Deborah Taylor, Coordinator
of School and Student Services
at Enoch-Pratt Free Library,
and Lisa Von Draseck,
Curator of the Children's
Literature Research Collections
at the University of
Minnesota Libraries.
Each of these esteemed
advocates for children's books
and literacy was asked
to bring a short list
of their top five candidates
consideration based
on the following criteria.
1) Their contributions to
young people's to literature.
2) Their ability to relate to kids
and teens, and 3) Their dedication
to fostering children's
literacy as a whole.
Gene Yang's name appeared
on every, single list.
As every committee member well knew,
Gene has been an outstanding
advocate
for inclusion graphing
novels and reading for years,
and we knew it was about time to
formalize the vital role he serves
for our nation's young people.
Gene's platform, Reading Without
Walls, will focus on breaking
down barriers to reading,
championing diversity in all forms,
and engaging young
readers/nonreaders,
and that could not be
more timely and impactful.
Gene, we are honored and delighted
that you have accepted the position
as our Fifth National Ambassador
for Young People's Literature
and could not be more excited to
share your message with children
and caregivers across the
country for the next two years.
I would also like to
extend our gratitude
to this year's National
Ambassador Program sponsors,
HarperCollins Children's Books,
McMillan Children's Publishing
Group, Penguin Young Readers Group,
Random House Children's Books,
Scholastic, Simon & Schuster Book
for Young Readers, and the
Lois Lenski Covey Foundation.
Generosity makes all
this profitable.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
>> John Cole: it's my pleasure
to, once again, introduce the time
for a few comments, Kate DiCamillo,
who is the outgoing, so to speak,
National Ambassador for
Young People's Literature.
Kate, as I think Jon mentioned in
part, is an award-winning author
who did a wonderful job
for us the last two years.
We have been lucky in all of our
ambassadors, and it's been, in part,
because as Jon mentioned, we've
had a skilled, dedicated crew
of people recommending, but
in part, it's the individuals.
Once they're in this
position and realize
that the opportunity is there
to really impress young people
and their parents about
reading and its importance,
which has developed a new way
of doing it, and Kate is going
to talk a little bit about herself,
but also about another ambassador
and the importance of what
we've been doing together.
The final point is that on
the Library of Congress site,
each ambassador does appear
at our National Book Festival.
It so happens that Gene already has
been at our National Book Festival,
but Kate, John, Katherine,
and Walter Dean Myers all became
veterans of the Book Festival,
and in that sense, they contributed
greatly to the national book culture
that we're trying to create
here at the Library of Congress.
Please welcome Kate DiCamillo.
Kate.
[ Applause ]
>> Kate DiCamillo: We're going
to get to Gene, I promise.
So how are you all doing?
Good? Okay.
Can I just say something
when I put my glasses on?
That one of the best things that
happened to me in the two years
that I was ambassador was
when I was in South Dakota,
and I was in an auditorium
that had 900 kids in it,
and they were fabulous,
and one kid raised her hand
and asked how old I was,
and I said, "I'm 50."
And she said, "But
how did that happen?"
And I think of that every time
I put the reading glasses on,
and it's like I don't know.
You know, it will happen to you too.
When Walter Dean Myers was
a young man, he read a story
by James Baldwin entitled
Sonny's Blues.
That story, Walter said,
gave him a permission
that he didn't know he needed.
The permission to write about
his own landscape, his own map.
Walter Dean Myers felt that there
was no greater calling than to do
for others what Sonny's
Blues had done for him,
and Walter did exactly that.
His words give permission.
His books are maps.
He held up the light that let
us see ourselves and the others.
Two years ago, Walter
stood at this podium
and passed some of his light to me.
I tried my best to carry it high,
to honor Walter, to honor Catherine
and Jon, and to honor books
and their power to connect us
and to help us see each
other, and today, I feel very,
very lucky to pass this
light, Walter's light,
onto the incomparable Gene Yang.
Thank you for these past two years.
Thank you for letting
me hold the light.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Yes, our
new ambassador is next.
You are about to personally
experience Gene's passion
for reading, his passion for books,
and he's going to talk a little bit
about his theme of inclusiveness.
Reading Without Walls.
Gene is a Michael Prinz winner.
He's won lots of awards, but his
career is really moving up fast now
with more awards and more
recognition in many different ways.
The American Library Association
bestows the Prinz Award each year
for the best book written for teens,
written entirely on
its literary merit.
Gene will cover a little of
this, but let me explain quickly,
just in case he doesn't, and
then he may not have to go
into too much depth on this part.
He's been drawing comics
since the fifth grade.
He first found success in
1997 when he received a grant
for his Gordon Yamamoto
in The King of Greeks,
which was eventually published as a
comic book by a comic book company.
During this time, Gene received
a master's degree in education
at California State at Hayward
and began teaching
school in San Francisco.
I've mentioned, in passing,
the first graphic novel
of Gene's American-Born Chinese
was enormously successful,
and the first graphic novel
to be named a finalist
for the National Book Award.
The book is about a teenager
struggling with his identity,
a theme that is common
in much of Gene's work,
which emphasizes the importance of
celebrating our diverse culture.
It was American-Born Chinese
that won the Prinz Award.
Boxers and Saints, which comprises
two companion graphic novels,
was Gene's next solo work,
and it also was a National
Book Award Finalist.
Gene is currently writing the
graphic novel series Secret Coders,
which teaches young people about
computer programming, believe it
or not, and it's said if I read that
book, I could become a computer.
So I'm going to give it
a try, Gene, I promise.
Please welcome Gene, our
new National Ambassador
for Young People's Literature.
Gene Yang.
[ Applause ]
>> Good morning, everyone.
Thank you so much for being here.
I seriously cannot tell you
how excited, how honored,
and how thrilled I am to be here.
I'm going to start by thanking
a whole bunch of people.
There are lots of people to thank.
So please bear with me.
First, I want to thank God for
both the blessings and trials.
Second only to God I want to
thank the Library of Congress,
Every Child a Reader, and
the Children's Book Council,
not just for this opportunity,
but also for caring so deeply
about the young people
of this nation,
for wanting to share the wonders
of books and wonders of reading
with every child in America.
I want to thank all of my
predecessors at this post.
I want to thank Kate and
Walter and Katherine and Jon.
You guys have truly created a
legacy of light, and I feel honored
to be a part of that legacy.
I'd like to thank all the good
people at McMillan Children's
and First-Second Books, John
Sargent, Jonathan Yagen,
Simon Boutin, Angus Killick, Allison
Verost, Costa Brill, Gina Gagliano,
and especially Mark Siegel.
First-Second Books,
just over 10 years ago,
First-Second Books was a glimmer
in Mark's eye, and now it is a home
for me and storytellers like me.
That's a really amazing thing.
I'd like to thank my agent,
Judy Hansen, for your wisdom
and guidance, my lovely wife,
Teresa, who is my partner
in everything, and also my family
for their undying support, and last
but not least, I want
to thank all of you,
especially if you skipped
school to be here.
You so much.
[laughter] Now I'm going to start
by telling you a little bit,
something about myself
that you may not know.
I am a nerd.
I know a lot of you are
looking at me and going, "Wow,
that guy kind of looks
like a pro wrestler."
But I am not a pro wrestler.
I'm a nerd.
I like the things that
nerdy people like.
I like superhero comics.
I like computers, and my
nerdiness really solidified
when I was in fifth grade.
That was when I really fell in love
with both superhero
comics and computers.
Going to tell you exactly
how that happened.
I fell in love with superhero comics
because of this book
here right here.
Oh, this is what I looked like
in fifth grade, by the way.
Now I fell in love with superhero,
because of this book right here.
This is Marvel Comics Two in One.
The series that they don't
really publish anymore,
but this is where Marvel Comics
would take two of their characters
that didn't normally hang out
together and them together
to have some kind of adventure.
For this issue, it was The
Thing and Rom The Space Knight.
I thought the two characters
looked amazing.
I saw this at my local bookstore.
I brought it up to my mom.
I said, "Mom, I need to own this.
Can you please buy it for me?"
She looked at cover, and she
said, "No, absolutely not.
Those two characters
look way too scary,
and they're going to
give you nightmares."
And she maybe put this
back on the spinner rack.
To this day, I really have no
idea what this story is all about,
but my mom, being a good
mom, decided buy me a comic.
She decided to buy me the
latest Superman comic.
I have to tell you,
when I was a kid,
I was not a huge fan of Superman.
I thought he was kind of boring,
but it's obvious why my mom chose
to buy me a Superman comic, right?
Because Superman is every
parent's favorite superhero.
He's not scary looking at all.
He's actually kind of good-looking.
He always does the right thing.
He never says any bad words.
He doesn't punch anybody unless
he really has to, and afterwards,
feels kind of bad about it.
He flies around in
this blue uniform,
like this giant flying
Boy Scout fighting crime.
I brought this book home.
I was disappointed,
but I still read it,
and in this book the
atomic bomb drops in 1986.
His 1984 as I'm reading it.
So the atomic bomb drops.
It kills off to the
people in the world.
The few remnants of humanity
that are left gather themselves
in these little societies
that are pretty lawless.
So a group of men have
to get together dressed
up in Medieval-style armor and
ride around the countryside
on these giant mutated
dogs to fight crime.
Superman teams up with these guys.
They call themselves
the Atomic Knights,
and they have this
adventure together.
In the last few pages of this story,
it's revealed that the
whole thing is just a dream,
but that did not stop this book
from completely freaking me out.
I stayed up nights
thinking about it.
I also stayed up nights thinking
about comics, how the combination
of words and pictures did
something inside my brain
that neither words nor pictures
had been able to do alone.
Pretty soon, after buying this book,
I went from being a comic book
reader to comic book creator.
Fifth grade, I have
this friend by the name
of Jeremy Kinyoshi
[assumed spelling],
half Jewish, half Japanese kid.
He was a veteran comic
book geek in fifth grade.
He'd been collecting
comics since he could read,
and together, we made stories.
We made comics.
We would brainstorm plots together.
Then I would do all the pencils.
He would do all the inks.
We give all of our original art to
his mom who would take them to work,
wait until all her coworkers went
home, and sneak photocopies for us.
Then we take these photocopies.
We'd staple them by hand.
We sold them to our
classmates for 50 cents a piece.
We made $8.
It was amazing.
Jeremy has since given up on comics.
He is now a radiologist.
He lives in a giant house in
Hawaii, but I did not, oops,
I did not give up on comics.
I kept making comics all the
way until now, until now.
So that's how I fell
in love with comics.
How I fell in love with computers
was through this machine right here.
This is an Apple 2E.
Any of you remember an Apple 2E?
You all know what that is.
Those of you who don't
know what a Apple 2E,
visit your local technology museum.
There will be one there.
Now the Apple 2E compared
to computers today is just
not very powerful, right?
It could only display
the color green.
It was very slow.
Didn't even have a hard drive, so
you couldn't even store anything
on it, but I loved this computer,
because this is the computer
I learned how to program on.
My fifth grade year, the summer
right after my grade year,
started off spectacularly.
I spent every day off in
front of the television.
I watched a lot of Reading Rainbow,
but I didn't read any of the books.
My mom watched me do this,
and she was kind of disgusted.
So she signed me up for these
summer enrichment classes.
Now, 30 years later,
I don't remember any
of those summer enrichment
classes except for one of them.
I took an introduction to
computer programming class.
In that class, we learned
the language called LOGO.
LOGO is a language which
is kind of forgotten now,
but if you had learned computer
programming in the 70s or 80s,
you most likely learned LOGO.
There are all sorts of
reasons why LOGO is awesome,
but my favorite feature
of this language is
there's this little turtle.
The turtle doesn't look like this.
Normally it looks like
this, because graphics
in the 80s were just not
very good, but what you do
in LOGO is you could give us turtle
instructions, and it would move
around the screen and draw stuff.
So you could do really
simple designs like this.
You can add the simple
designs together
to make more complex designs,
or you could do these beautiful
geometric designs like this.
What I learned that summer was that
computers are a way to make art,
and I've always been
interested in art.
That's how I fell in
love with computers.
So in fifth grade, my
nerdiness was solidified,
and I've been a nerd
ever sense, but today,
I'm not just a nerd, I
am also an ambassador.
I first found out in October.
My editor, Mark, called me up.
I kind of freaked out a little
bit, but after I freaked out,
I also wondered what exactly
does an ambassador do?
What exactly is an ambassador?
I had a few email exchanges with
Kate, and she was amazingly helpful,
but I also consulted that source
of answers that all nerds go to.
So I knew that ambassadors
had to wear fancy suits.
I also knew they wore fancy metals,
but when I consulted that source
of answers, that source
of answers, by the way is,
of course, superhero comics.
Superhero comics don't have the
answers to all of life's questions,
but they definitely have most of
them, and the superhero comic answer
to the question what exactly is an
ambassador is this lady right here.
>> Audience Speaker: Wonder Woman!
>> Gene Yang: You all
know who this is?
This is Wonder Woman.
She is one of my favorite
superheroes.
Wonder woman and I have a
lot in common, actually.
First, we both have black hair.
We both are a lot stronger than
we look, and I have to tell you,
it's a lot harder for
her to pull this off,
because she actively look strong,
and we also both look
great in red boots.
Now I don't really have a photo to
show you this to prove it to you,
but you've just got to imagine.
I look amazing in red boots.
Today, we have even more common,
because Wonder Woman is also an
ambassador, which means she also,
from time to time, puts on a fancy
suit and wears a fancy metal,
and Wonder Woman is from an
island called Paradise Island.
Paradise Island only has women.
No men. Which might be why
it's called Paradise Island.
But the women of Paradise Island
call themselves the Amazons,
and one day, this man, this
fighter pilot named Steve Trevor,
crashes on Paradise Island.
The Amazons rescue him.
They're not sure what
to do with him.
They're not sure how to relate to
Steve Trevor's world, our world,
so in the end, they decide
to send wonder woman
out as their ambassador.
Wonder Woman is supposed
to promote understanding
of Amazon culture to
the outside world.
As an author, I am from
the world of books,
and that's kind of like my job too.
I'm supposed to promote
understanding of the world
of books among children
and their caretakers.
Here's the thing though,
books are also ambassadors.
Books have been ambassadors
in my life.
Let me explain to you
how this happened.
So as we get older,
one of the things
that we do is we figure
out who we are.
We figure out the different
pieces of our identity.
So I'll give you myself
as an example.
I am a Chinese-American.
I love computers.
I love superhero comics.
I also love drawing.
I've been drawing since
I was two years old.
That's what my mom tells me anyway.
I don't really remember,
and I love books.
So as we get older, we collect
all these pieces to who we are,
and then eventually, we put
a wall around these pieces.
Walls are not necessarily
a bad thing.
After all, walls define what a home
is, and this graphic, in a sense,
represents what my home is.
This is where I am most
comfortable, but walls can be bad
if you never go outside of them.
If you never go outside your walls,
then your home is essentially
a prison.
I am not a sports guy.
I have never been really
good at sports.
I've never been a fan of sports,
and I've especially not
been a fan of basketball.
For some reason, whenever
I play basketball,
the ball always hits me in the head.
It's like my head is
magnet for basketballs.
So growing up, even
after I became an adult,
I made sure to keep
basketball outside
of my walls and away from my head.
As adults, we keep
our walls with us.
Sometimes they even solidify
for us as we become adults,
and we even have these
walls when we're teachers.
I was a high school teacher for 17
years at Bishop O'Dowd High School.
This is what our campus looks like,
Bishop O'Dowd High School,
has anyone heard of us?
Nobody? We're kind of famous.
You should have heard of us.
We are like the best school
in all of Oakland, California.
In any case, even teachers
have these walls.
Let me give you an example.
This is a drawing of what our
faculty lunch room looked.
The PE teachers and at one table.
The drama teachers sat at another
table, and the nerdy teachers
that at yet another table.
There were a couple teacher that
would go from one table to the next,
but for the most part,
we teachers stayed
where we were most comfortable.
We also had our walls.
Every now and then,
however, something happens
to make us go outside of
our walls, and for me,
books played a key role in that.
I told you already that one of the
pieces, one of those icons inside
of my walls is my Chinese-American
heritage.
That's something I'm
really interested in,
something that really
care a lot about.
One day I came across this
book called Outside the Paint
by Kathleen Yep.
Kathleen Yep has these
older relatives who all grew
up in San Francisco Chinatown.
This is a book about
Chinese-American culture.
These older relatives
of the author's,
they came from very
poor, immigrant families.
They didn't really have a lot
of money, and what they did
for fun was they played basketball.
They played a lot of basketball.
Both the girls and the boys
were obsessed with the game.
In fact, for a couple of decades,
the San Francisco Youth Basketball
Leagues were all dominated
by these Chinese teams.
I read this book.
It was a ton of fun.
It was very fast-paced.
It was about a corner of
Chinese-American history
that I knew nothing about, but
it was also about this topic
that was clearly outside
of my walls.
It was about basketball.
I enjoyed this book so much that
I decided to find other books
about basketball and read them,
and here are just a few of them.
The first one, Slam Dunk, is one
of the most popular Manga
series in the world.
It's about a Japanese high
school basketball team,
and their pursuit of
their championship.
Ball Don't Lie is by a
superstar young author
by the name of Matt de la Pena.
Matt and I are friends.
I'm just kind of name
dropping right there,
but Matt isn't just a great writer.
He is also a great basketball
player, and his book really draws
on his experiences as both a Mexican
American and a basketball there
to tell a wonderful
story, and the final one,
The Crossover by Kwame Alexander
recently won The Newberry,
one of the biggest book
prizes in all of America.
This is an extraordinary book
because the author is able
to capture the rhythm
of a basketball game
through the rhythm of his words.
I read these books, and these
books acted like ambassador to me.
They were in ambassador to
the world of basketball.
They allowed me to
understand a world
that I was never really part of.
I read these books.
I got kind of excited
about basketball.
I want to talk to somebody about it.
So I started talking to
this guy named Lou Ritchie.
Lou Ritchie was another teacher
at Bishop O'Dowd High School.
He was a PE teacher.
He's also the coach of the
varsity men's basketball team.
Now this is what he looks
like in the yearbook.
This is what he looks
like as a cartoon.
Lou's a great guy,
but he is not the kind
of guy I would normally
be friends with.
After all, he sat at
a different table.
He's also an athlete, and I am a
nerd, but as we started talking
about basketball, we
slowly became friends.
Lou invited me to go watch
the games of his team.
So I even got to travel
with this team.
There's this big tournament
in Missouri.
This is a photo from that
tournament, and as I traveled
with this team, I learned
how to watch basketball.
I'm definitely no expert.
I don't think I have like
70% of the rules memorized.
But now I get it.
I understand why basketball
is important.
I understand why people like
it, and as I followed this team,
I got to know Lou a little better.
What I discovered is that he and I
actually have a lot more in common
than I originally thought.
For instance, Lou loves
books just like I do.
He especially loves
reading history books.
Lou also loves numbers.
Now I love number too, even
though I didn't include that icon
in my previous picture
with the walls and it.
Lou loves numbers so much
that he memorizes basketball
and baseball statistics for fun.
He had so many of these statistics
memorized that when he was a kid,
the kids in his neighborhood
used to call him The Professor.
So Lou isn't just an athlete.
He's also a nerd.
He's like a nerdlete.
I even have photographic
evidence of this.
This is what Lou looked
like when he was a kid.
His glasses are just as big as mine.
So I followed this
team for a season.
I got to talk with Lou and the
other coaches and the other players.
I even got to sit in on
their locker room chats.
I could hear their pep talks.
I got to look at their
strategies, and during the season,
what I discovered was an
amazing, compelling story.
It was their story.
It was a story that was
so compelling that I felt
like I needed to do a book about it.
So my next book is actually
my first nonfiction book.
It'll be a graphic novel
about this basketball team.
I'm kind of giving away the ending
with this picture right here.
So don't tell anybody.
So books were really
ambassadors for me.
Books allowed me to understand
basketball a little bit better,
which led to my friendship
with Lou, which in turn led
to me following him and his
team around for a season,
which led to me now doing
a book about basketball.
Books can be ambassadors
for you, too.
They can be ambassadors
in your lives too.
I'm going to give you just a few
examples of how it can happen.
Number one, they can be
ambassadors into the lives of people
who are different from you.
People from different
cultural traditions.
People from different religions.
People different ways of life.
Number two, books can be
ambassadors into topics
that you might find intimidating.
For me, that was basketball.
I talked to a lot of folks who find
STEM topics intimidating, science,
technology, engineering, and
math, and there's some amazing,
amazing books that can act as
your ambassador into those topics.
Books can even be ambassadors
into other kinds of books.
So, for instance, maybe, you
pretty much only read prose books,
books with just words in them,
and you've never tried
a graphic novel before,
or maybe you're the exact opposite.
Maybe you only read graphic novels
and you never read books
with just words in them.
Well, there are plenty of
books that are hybrid books
that marry these two different
ways of telling stories together.
One of my favorites is
actually Ambassador Kate's book,
Flora and Ulysses, about
a superhero squirrel.
It's pretty amazing, but these
books can help you transition
from one kind of a
book to the other.
So I'd like to end my talk
with a challenge to you,
and my challenge is that
you read without walls.
Go find a book that you
normally wouldn't read.
This might be a book with someone
on the cover that doesn't like you
or doesn't live like you.
This might be a book about a topic
that you had previously
thought intimidating,
or this might be a book in a format
that you have never
really tried before.
Read without walls
and see what happens.
I guarantee, it's going
to be something amazing.
Thank you very much.
It was wonderful to have the
chance to talk to you all.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Gene,
that was wonderful,
and we've got it recorded, and
we're going to make use of it.
That's great.
I'd like to invite David to come
up to present Gene with his medal,
and I'd like to ask Jon and Kate
stand by for the photo opportunity
that will follow right after
this presentation here, and then,
if we have time, if we move through
this quickly, we'll have time
for a question or two from the kids
for Gene, but let's move ahead.
Thank you.
Right here, and then maybe we
could bring our photographers
who want to take a photo here.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
[ Applause ]
[ Background Discussion ]
[ Light Laughter ]
>> John Cole: Now, Jon Coleman.
Jon, come on up.
You and I will join this grand.
[ Background Discussion ]
We are determined to use the
last five minutes for a couple
of questions for Gene
from anybody who is
over here who might have question.
Is there a teacher or a child
who'd like to get started?
Here's one right here.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
>> Gene Yang: So the
question is how did I come
up with the idea of Secret Coders?
Secret Coders is a six-volume
graphic novel series all
about computer coding.
I said that I taught
high school for 17 years.
I talked computer science.
I taught kids how to code, and I
taught in this really visual way.
So I do a lot of drawing
on the board.
I was actually just kind of copying
my old computer science teacher
from when I was in high school, and
when I did that, I thought, "Man,
a lot of this could really
work as a graphic novel."
So it's been a project
that I've been thinking
about for really long time.
I'm really happy to
finally get to work on that.
>> Audience Speaker:
Good morning, Mr. Yang.
Have you ever done any
animation for any movies?
>> Gene Yang: Have I done
any animation for any movies?
You know, when I was
a kid, I really,
really wanted to be a Disney
animator, and in the end,
I decided to give up on that
because what I was really interested
in was story, you know?
And if you look at the animation
industry, an animatedly takes
like hundreds of people to make,
and out of those hundreds of people,
maybe only a handful have
any control over the story.
So I like books because
looks really give the author
or the cartoonist control
over the story.
So I've never really
done any sort animation.
Are you interested
in being an animator?
>> Audience Speaker: Yes.
>> Gene Yang: You've
got to draw like crazy.
Carry a note -- a little
sketchbook with you all the time.
>> Audience Speaker:
Well, thank you.
>> Gene Yang: Yeah, thank you.
Keep drawing.
>> Audience Speaker: Mr.
Yang, what age were you
when you started writing
comic books?
>> Gene Yang: Well, I was that great
when I started writing comic books.
So I think I was -- I want to
say 10 or 11 when I did that.
I you interested in
writing books, as well?
Not really?
Think about it.
It will hit you.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
>> Audience Speaker: Who taught
you how to write comic books?
>> Gene Yang: Who told me
how to write comic books?
Stan Lee. Okay, so when I
the kid, I read this book.
It was called How to Draw Comics the
Marvel Way by a guy named Stan Lee.
Do you know who he is?
I bet you know what he made.
He created The Fantastic
Four, he created Spiderman,
and he created The Avengers.
So in How to Draw Comic the Marvel
Way, he taught me how to write
and draw comic books, but
the thing is, when I realized
after I became an adult is that not
every comic book is made the Marvel
way, and that might not even be
the best way of making comics.
So if you're interested in
writing comics or making comics,
I would encourage you to do
some exploration and figure
out what the best way is for you.
>> Audience Speaker:
Good morning, Mr. Yang.
Mr. Yang, Mr. Yang, what inspired
you to make Secret Coders?
>> Gene Yang: What inspired
me to make Secret Coders?
Have you read it yet?
>> Audience Speaker: Yes.
>> Gene Yang: You did?
Thanks for reading it.
Okay, so the main character
of Secret Coders is a little
girl named Hopper who learns how
to become a computer programmer, and
Hopper is actually inspired by one
of the most famous computer
scientists in the world.
Her name is Grace Hopper.
She's no longer with us, but
a lot of people don't realize
that computer programming
started off
as what was considered
a woman's profession.
A lot of the early computer
programmers were women.
The very first computer program
in the world was a woman a woman
by the name of Ada Loveless,
an English mathematician.
So Hopper, Grace Hopper,
was really the inspiration
of my character, Hopper.
>> Audience Speaker: Mr. Yang,
what was your first book?
>> Gene Yang: Which
was my first book?
The very first book that I did when
I was a kid was a superhero book.
That's what I did with Jeremy,
who I showed you earlier.
The first book that I did as an
adult was called Gordon Yamamoto
and The King of The Geeks.
It was about a young man
who gets a spaceship stuck
in his nose becomes friends with
the alien that's driving a ship.
Thankfully, that is
hard to find now.
That book.
[ Laughter ]
[ Background Discussion ]
>> Audience Speaker: Oh, Mr. Yang,
again, do you do other comic books
like besides Superman, Batman,
Justice League comic books.
>> Gene Yang: Well, I
only work on Superman.
Are you a fan of Superman?
Who do you like better,
Superman or Batman?
>> Audience Speaker: Well, it's a --
>> Gene Yang: There's
a right answer here.
[ Laughter ]
>> Audience Speaker: Well, there's
going to be a movie called --
coming out against a
Superman and Batman.
>> Gene Yang: Yeah, so
who are you rooting for?
>> Audience Speaker:
Well, and four of Superman
because he's got the [inaudible]
power, and heat vision.
>> Gene Yang: That's right.
That's right.
Good answer.
Well, so I only work on
Superman for DC Comics,
but I do do a bunch of
other comic, as well.
I write Avatar, The Last Airbender
Nickelodeon and for Dark Horse.
You know that comic?
Okay, it's based on a
really popular TV show,
and that I do American-Born
Chinese and Boxers and Saints,
and a bunch of other books
with First-Second Books.
Oh, thank you.
>> Audience Speaker:
Do you speak Chinese?
>> Gene Yang: I do.
Do you? Do you speak
any other languages?
>> Audience Speaker: No.
>> Gene Yang: Okay, so I
have some advice for you.
When I was a kid, my parents
put me in Chinese school.
So every weekend on Saturday, when
other kids were watch cartoons,
I would have to go to
Chinese school, they told me,
"You need to pay attention.
Otherwise, as an adult,
you're going to regret it."
I did not pay attention, and
as an adult, I regret it.
So I would encourage you to go
and take a foreign language class
and pay attention so you
don't regret it as an adult.
>> John Cole: Two more
questions, just two.
>> Audience Speaker: Mr. Yang,
did you ever get the
book that you wanted?
>> Gene Yang: Which book?
>> Audience Speaker: The book that
you wanted when you was a kid.
>> Gene Yang: Oh, oh,
the book that --
the one with green cover
with Thor and The Thing.
You know, I have to tell you, one
of my former students saw me do
that presentation, and he
bought it for me for Christmas,
but I haven't read it yet,
because I feel if I read it,
I'm going to ruin that joke, right?
So it's just sitting in my room.
[ Background Discussion ]
>> Audience Speaker: Mr. Yang,
have you ever wanted to do a comic,
but you didn't have the inspiration?
>> Gene Yang: Okay, so your question
is have I ever wanted to do a comic
but I haven't had the inspiration?
Is that a problem that
you have had yourself?
>> Audience Speaker: No.
>> Gene Yang: Do you any
sort of stories or anything?
Okay, awesome.
So are you able to go from
beginning to end without stopping,
or do you sometimes run
out of steam in the middle.
>> Audience Speaker:
Sometimes, but not all the time.
>> Gene Yang: You sometimes
run out of steam in the middle?
Yeah, so for me, normally,
at the beginning of the book,
I have all sorts of inspiration.
Then when I get to the middle,
things sometimes get kind of dicey.
Like, it starts getting hard,
and what I found is you just have
to keep a regular time in your day
or in your week to
work on that book.
You've got to work on it, even
when you don't feel inspirational.
I mean, I've got to say,
it's kind of like a marriage.
You've just got to stick to it.
I mean, not my marriage.
Not a marriage.
But a theoretical marriage.
But you've got to stick with
it until one of you is dead
or one of you is finished.
Either you or that book is finished.
That's what you've got to do.
>> John Cole: I think I
have to bail Jean out here.
Give him a hand.
>> Gene Yang: Thank you.
>> John Cole: It's
really been wonderful.
Don't leave quite yet.
Remember the students are
going to be leaving first.
Gene, you may sit.
You've done enough, I tell you.
It's been wonderful.
But I wish to thank the staff, not
only of the Children's Book Council,
but of the Center for the Book, and
especially The Young Readers Center.
For putting this together,
for the planning
and for the hard work
that's gone in.
I'd like to thank the
judges in the sponsors
who put this program
together for the past,
this is our fifth ambassador,
as you know.
We didn't know how it
would go when it started.
It's really gone beautifully.
It's been a program of
substance and of style,
and it's because of
the participation
of the people I just mentioned and
the kids, who were great today.
A final round of applause for Gene,
and then let the kids go first.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.